so I think this is a bit of a different
talk that's of a technical talk but I
thought it might be interesting to share
some well stylized experiences from my
time in open source I've been working
well in open source with well as a user
and a contributor maybe since 10 years
SK time started five or six years ago
and this session is also meant as a bit
of an advice to anyone who is
contributing to or even perhaps in a
leading role in open source project so
sumon disclaimer ah had I'm giving this
presentation my role as academic
researchers at University of Budapest as
citizen of Hungary opinions presented as
solely my own in line with freedom of
research and arts guaranteed by various
apical jurisdictions presentation except
slide 15 is not given behalf
representation of SK time Community but
consent where consent would be required
no identifiability of actual persons
groups of persons organizations or
actual events is intended mention the
depictions of IND identifiable
historical persons are intended in a
purely metaphorical sense I acknowledge
qu of conduct accessible through pil web
page uh 30 minutes ago and I'm giving
the presentation in i'mm belief it is
not in violation thereof all right so
let's start with the SK time mission
statement and uh with an explanation of
where this actually is coming from what
this is aiming at so SK time as you
might know it is a comprehensive python
framework for machine learning and AI
with time series and this mission
statement was consciously chosen
consciously constructed in a certain way
so it's op permissive license free to
use but very importantly in our mission
in our DNA we have written that we are
openly and transparently governed by the
user and developer community and so this
includes users with a charitable core as
a community we want to be friendly kind
and inclusive with an active commitment
to fairness and equal opportunity we
want to be academically and commercially
neutral also important as well as an
educational platform providing mentoring
and upskilling opportunities to
potentially everyone I want to highlight
the openly and transparently governed by
the user and developer Community with
the charitable core so why is this
important it is important by because of
the following distinction which is I
think often not very well
emphasized um so there's of course
graduations here but I want to I want to
point out a contrast and in recent years
the market has gotten heated up quite a
lot and we see different models here so
commercial open source versus inclusive
open source and what do I mean by that
so commercial we have open source
projects which are controlled Maybe by
one company few decision makers there's
closed gatekeeping when it comes to
decision making or decision- making on
benefits whereas in the inclusive model
at least in in what one can strive for
is distributed control joint decision-
making open onboarding model and
benefits being distributed fairly and
broadly of course there's a variety of
definitions of fair here that one could
apply but the importance is the openness
to onboarding and the openness the um
traversability of decision-making layers
now common points of confusion here on
the commercial side there's a frequent
use of words like open or democratizing
where one wouldn't say open it's open in
the sense of an open Society for
instance it might be open source or open
license in the sense but the decision
making the governance model might not be
open and also um on the um inclusive
side right if you have Merit on board
based onboarding that's not necessarily
closed there is the free versus open
software discussion historically and I
would see this is actually unrelated to
this distinction here there's also I
would I want to point out a an important
impact on users on the commercial side
you're typically on a lock in or upsell
trajectory so upselling deployment lock
in in the sense of uh trying to keep you
there with the software Solutions based
on the software there's an ecosystem
fragmentation effect in my opinion
commercial pressures making the provided
Solutions or the provided information
not necessarily neutral whereas on the
inclusive
side SI also would see it as a vision
for SK time the uh it's a story of user
IND developer empowerment integrative
integration on the ecosystem level and
on the contributor
level to give you some
um illustration of what commercial
pressures could look like let's look at
how typical kpis for a commercial open
source project could look like so kpi
would typically include kpis on
contributor
engagement so Stars contributors pool
requests user Community engagement and
I'm mentioning this in the sense of if
you're looking at a company or a startup
who uses open source as part of their
business model these might
be uh these this might be the iron kpi
that such a company or startup would be
dealing with so I'm not inventing this
this is if you're familiar with for
instance Silicon Valley startup like
circles are not unrealistic numbers here
now here's the question why why is it
worth this amount of money why would
anyone pay for this right and the story
here is around uh a certain exploitation
Model A Certain growth model so of
course we have the seed which is an
initial investment create the open
source project get contributors on board
get users on board then the middle phase
it's called a strategy called Product
let growth so the idea there is to have
the word on the project spread by itself
users recruit more users developers
recruit more developers there is a low
entry barrier which attracts uh which
attracts users and contributors alike
and users are used as salese here it's
called the product Le uh product Le
growth model and this actually leads to
exponential growth in the best case you
get something uh like a unicorn Dynamics
now of course if you see it and you grow
at the end there is a Harvest so one
potential end game here is when the
growth
plateaus there's a harvest model there
you upsell lockin
users if the project is owned by a small
set of decision makers investors
corporate then this is a viable
strategy lockin upsell or migrate and of
course transfer of benefits are uh
happens to these investor circles
now this is I would also say not an
uncommon
model though in AI machine learning open
source I think it has been appearing
only relatively recently but this means
there's a change in weather there's a
change in conditions for open- Source
models which classically are coming from
a more participative more inclusive
philosophy it means there's increase in
direct competition the fragment ation of
the ecosystem refusal or at least
disincentives to collaborate
across across project boundaries and
heavy advertising by commercial actors
there's also adversarial
Dynamics through simply Market pressures
you can observe these kinds of dynamic
on any heated market so capture attempts
takeover attempts if you followed recent
news completely unrelated to this
presentation I'm giving why you can
observe a lot of games of thrones type
Dynamics in the area interference
disruption destructive action but also
in in the sense of incentives there're
incentives which can also go against the
uh the inclusive philosophy of a project
from in from within the project not
necessarily from external actors if uh
if you see the value
um the commercial value of projects
potentially now on users there's also an
impact on users of Open Source so
there's
increasing uh weight of the commercial
choices in the open source space or
commercially controlled choices with a
look into trajectory there's increasing
overclaiming noise so it's more
difficult to see to decide okay what is
actually what is the project doing
actually what is the actual governance
of the project and I would also diagnose
a loss of sovereignty in the user from
the user perspective because open source
no longer guarantees or use of Open
Source no longer guarantees that you
actually remain independent with your
internal software ecosystem as perhaps
it has it has been more the case in ages
past open source has become a market has
become a competition of products but it
has also become a competition of systems
namely the more commercial system and
the more classical so for instance
dating back to for instance how the Unix
communities work your initial python
communities work the inclusive system is
increasingly hard to navigate both for
users but also for contributors
developers and decision makers in the
area all right so second part of this
presentation the storm is coming it
cannot be avoided but how do you thrive
against adversity how do you sail
through the storm and here I want to
clarify that this is
um stylized statements from a strategic
and tactical perspective as I said at
the start identifiability of situations
events individuals or organizations here
is not intended now let's start first
with looking at the landscape looking at
the market so the story of this slide is
I want to reemphasize the higher the
value the higher uh the more complex
your threat and opportunity landscape
gets so let so on the top left to right
you have things getting more expensive
and you can think of it of course in
total value or yearly yearly gross or
something like that right so on the left
you have the content on your wallet on
the right you have the value of nation
state
economies
actors not much as changed here of
course normal people had are have as
disposable value to use on and actions
of any kind maybe Max few thousands 10
thousands 100 thousands couple of
dollars but as organization complexity
increases right you have nation state
economies on the very right with
trillions of dollars now where does
python open source sit in this right we
have the AI Revolution and I want to
emphasize this is what I think are
realistic perceived values
so perceived values of having full
control of
something okay so this is how I would
currently localize the value of say
certain types of AI data science open
source projects in the landscape so if
you have a random python package maybe
it's not worth much but if it's already
something with AI and it does not have a
substantial user base then the perceived
value is already maybe five six digits
right something
like SK time right you see startups you
see you see startups which provide
similar Solutions and you look at what
have
investors how much money have investors
thrown at the comparable solution but
which is now corporate controlled and
you're easily in the value of multiple
millions of dollars if you look at
something like psychic learn well it's
hard to estimate of course but you could
think you're already in ranges right
you're in ranges which are comparable to
contemporary open-source based software
unicorns and so these are I think
realistic ranges in which we're moving
and risks the risk and threat landscape
is in proportion to the perceived value
because let's say you an investor or a
group of investors a company might very
logically they are they tend to act very
logically they look at something and
perceive a value then well there is of
course a spectrum of U of of bright and
and dark here but you have uh
adversarial strategems on the risk side
and you have opportunity actions like
investment which depending on the value
you may or may not encounter right so if
you have I don't know a a half-year-old
open source package right you might
already see dynamics that otherwise you
would see only in middle management that
of multinational companies and on the
higher
end the open-source AI data science
ecosystem is touching geopolitical
considerations of nation states that's
also I think interesting to observe so
the perceived value is inflating we're
still not at the end of the AI and data
science
Revolution so the opportunity and threat
landscape is also
evolving I also want to point out if
you're a user of one of these packages
you do have a vested interest in
ensuring that the system is stable and
sustainable especially for inclusive
governed packages open
packages where the user is not a product
but the user is in fact a valued
constituent of the
community all right so now let's move on
I want to move on to well
some
stylized tactical you can call it um so
if you're familiar with military thought
exercises or scenarios let's go through
some scenarios here what Potential
Threat scenarios could look like and
what this implies based
on uh scenario examples for your
specific open source project and its
management if you're a contributor if
you're a user or a developer on the
project
the one pattern I think which is most
common I want to highlight here is
divide and conquer devided inum right on
the right hand so you see jel Caesar
here there's three stages to this
pattern so stage one infiltration
scouting exploring Rift potential so
common fracture points could be Academia
versus industry old versus new divs but
minority racism fault lines or
geopolitical topics which have nothing
to do with the open source project but
people might still feel uh they need to
start a discussion on these then stage
two is divide energy is expanded to
divide the community of the open source
project it also has a side effect that
energy is diverted within the community
so groups start constructing infighting
and there is no energy available anymore
to resist or
preempt the conquest and
consolidation so this is a general
pattern jwes Caesar conquering goal for
example but of course readers of the um
various uh uh Evergreens in the strategy
and tactics uh literature will of course
know that this applies also very much to
corporate tactics and strategies counter
measures stage one of course we have
early detection stage two and that's
very important because that is typically
the stage of detection do not take the
bait it's important that within the
community right if there might be
emotional pressures but it is important
for instance to do not to not take the
bait start
infighting and lose sight of what is
happening around
you in the market in the conquest stage
usually it's typically too late because
of the resource imbalance you are in uh
if you're an inclusive open source
Community uh you have a problem with
with the resource imbalance you have
much less for instance than a than a
large or even a multinational company so
then again resistance is one option but
nonviolent is important because any form
of violence aggression is taking the
bait if you know the history Jew Caesar
in this specific one it was violins also
was a bad
idea special
cases so number one scenario here I
would like to talk about so let's play
this through in the form of a military
exercise again
identifiability is not intended
highlighting the importance of a robust
legal and Def posture so concrete form
this divide and concrete could take for
instance so let's suppose you are a
small open source project and you're
looking for Public
Funding and you send a proposal but it
gets altered in the last minute and in
fact it's it turns out the grant agency
themselves changes the public records in
retrospect so the money ends up with a
different person then it should have
ended up with and that is then used to
take control of the project there is
various noise around it and attempted
board capture which is simultaneous with
an attack on the developer
asset in this scenario if you play it
out what could work immediate ejection
of persons involved in the scheme defs
preparations so let's suppose in this
scenario it enables retaking of most key
assets and legal action against
remaining key assets which
succeeds and the user Community might
also step in this case what in this case
could be unsuccessful of
course there's no way to know but let's
suppose this is how it plays out
whistleblowing with the grant agency
does not work complaints at the
University so going to going to all
these external parties that in this case
could help you does not help so external
COC process for instance as well so this
is a scenario where from within the
community the remedy has to come now
let's park this for a moment and see
what it means for the posture legal or
otherwise for the community second
scenario which will highlight the
importance of robust independent
arbitration so let's suppose the
following
happens
that board of an open source related
charity suddenly starts disseminating
fake accusations against one or multiple
persons in the community and these
accusations are of serious code of
conduct validation violations along
racial stereotypes this happens without
a code of conduct report having taken
place and without any discussions with
the accused having happened right the
person or Persons get banned from a
conference just days before the event an
event unrelated to the accusation and
liess content is disseminated throughout
the community so the community might now
think oh this one person has committed a
serious off and it's and it plays on
racial biases so it might actually be uh
racial stereotypes that are now being
confirmed suppose the defense plays out
in this case the community starts its
own proper code of conduct process
records are properly kept video
recordings consented are made and other
community members then step up and
travel to the conference so the
presentation is actually
held suppose in this scenario
the accuser tries
to use the Charity's own code of con
process but oh who replies well the same
person who disseminated these
accusations and the conference
contacting the conference results in
verbal threats and it's later revealed
that in fact the charity has done this
multiple times in the past or variations
of this so one could think there is
Method not an accident
right
recommendations recommendations for open
source
communities first for the community
itself stay safe stand together look out
for each other it is important that you
have internal robust arbitration
processes so functioning Court of
conduct arbitration committee is
important put process in place play it
out with scenarios like this what
happens if
test it in peace times and ensure that
there's robust mechanisms for
independent investigations and appeals
it's also interesting that from a
strategic perspective arbitration
mechanisms are common first targets or
you could tactically think they are it's
important to look out for individual
safety so keep contact with your support
network outside the context family
friends feel free to discuss things with
them they might be your source of energy
and mental health and monitor your own
mental health know what is gaslighting
know what is burnout and watch for
emotional activation because if it
compels you to fast short reactions
these reactions are usually not in your
favor do not be a bystander avoid saking
or blaming learn about nonviolent
deescalation and intervention
familiarize yourself with victim blaming
mobbing best practice in harassment and
bullying cases if you have a role don't
run don't fight without
thinking remove yourself from emotions
think about fact finding and also to
right to site di Bon first they come for
the weakest and then they come for
others so if you spot any Dynamic you
might spot them most easily with those
individuals of your community who are
the
weakest and of course as a decision
maker as a leader in a community it is
your
responsibility to also protect them do
not be a
bystander talking about legal posters in
the first scenario we have seen taking
control of assets right how this plays
out how can you be safe from that so
safeguarding assets trademark
registration incorporation are
safeguards if you are
unincorporated then using a third
party's brand so let's say you put
someone else's logo on your project and
you don't own a trademark you don't it's
not a company or a charity then it gives
this third party an enforcable claim of
your assets they can in principle pull
the rug out from under you and get
ownership of your say GitHub and pii
account so have legal support contacts
and emergency plan ready do not lightly
sign away assets to third parties even
if they say oh we have the best interest
of you in mind and have a plan if
someone from the community signs a
contract unauthorized in the name of the
community operational security is
important Safeguard your assets
multiactor
Authority F Factor authentication
separation of Duties Dev obsc all these
topics you can look up important very
important important assets if you're at
python package the PPI project GitHub
repository social media Keys have
emergency plans in place within the
community do not give the keys easily
away to people even if you trust them
it's safer if you ensure the assets
remain within legal reach so if you have
legal Provisions made for only the
European Union you should for instance
ensure the keys remain only within the
European Union governance ensure you
have clear decision-making
responsibilities agility in emergency
cases ensure separation of powers for
instance independent arbitration I've
mentioned that already keep written
records minutes optimally public
transparent minutes meeting records and
if fire start start documenting
screenshots consented video captures
store material in multiple safe
locations if you need it
later okay wrapping up Where Do We Go
From Here what is the future of course
the landscape is changing threats but
also opportunities and we are talking
about opportunities and I think that as
the landscape changes the inclusive open
source projects need to change with
them and inclusive means we need you you
cannot wait for other people to take
responsibility for you it means you who
are watching this video or present in
this talk Step Up contribute to
operations to Cod or funding functioning
of the communities and you can be
assured I'm speaking on this slide
specifically for the SK time Community
if you need our help if you want to
leverage the experiences that we have as
a community you have our help if you
need
it our mission I want to reiterate is to
be open and transparently governed we
are by the user and the developer
Community for the user and developer
Community we have a charitable core and
have committed to disseminate distribute
benefits
fairly to some extent it is already in
construct it is still in construction
but this is where we want to get to we
see our users we see our contributors as
constituents not Market potentials we
are currently moving towards a lean
inclusive setup for our community we
would love to talk to other inclusive
open source community
to connect to
interoperate we invite you to join us to
truly democratize AI in the sense of the
word we inspired by the Wikipedia model
currently but of course any ideas any
input any contributions are
appreciated right creating republics
takes some engineering thinking here
some mechanism thinking and it needs to
be a collaborative effort watch this
space follow us from LinkedIn join our
Discord you can find our Discord if you
go on the es time GitHub and message us
of course SK time the community council
you can easily find us on Discord if
this presentation has hopefully inspired
you thank you very much